one of tom clancy's most famous
characters john clark
we all know about him but what about his
origin story it's about to burst through
your screen
on amazon prime coming up later on this
week
he is the star of tom clancy's without
remorse michael
b jordan back here on the rich housing
show how have you been michael i'm doing
great man good to talk to you how you
doing
i am better for talking to you a lot has
happened a lot has happened in the three
four years since you were in my show
studio the last time congratulations
on all of that man thank you thank you
man it's been it's been an
incredible ride and journey um and and
i'm really really excited about you know
just where we are right now and being
able to talk to you about this project
also well yeah i i i gotta tell you in
terms of her journey what we've all been
on the last year
man like let's get our popcorn ready you
know what i mean like let's get
let's let's just go see a big time
film where somebody is kicking ass and
taking names without remorse and we
could just sit back
and enjoy it you know what i'm saying
yes
this is awesome no it happened at the
perfect you know the perfect time this
movie we actually finished shooting the
movie right before the pandemic hit
and we spent the entire last year trying
to figure out you know how we were going
to get this movie out for everybody to
to see so you know you know thankfully
you know we found a home in amazon and
and and they've been great partners and
you know making sure this movie gets out
to everybody
that could possibly uh watch it and and
um and yeah man
john john kelly john clark you know this
is like the
the movie that i grew up watching that i
always wanted to be in
you know and from playing the you know
the rainbow six ghost recon
video games as a kid right to actually
playing you know john clark in the movie
it kind of came full circle so it's it's
nothing short of an action-packed
revenge thriller
but grounded with a lot of heart and
stakes and characters so it's the
perfect kind of movie for me
where do you stand on you getting in and
doing everything that we see on the
screen
oh i mean i'm all for it you know i mean
watching movies like
you know you know blade wesley snipes
you know knowing he did all his stunts
or like you know jackie chan and tom
cruise and matt damon you know and all
these uh
you know these action stars that i grew
up you know idolizing and being like you
know what if i ever get the opportunity
i'm i'm training for it i'm doing
everything i could possibly do
and then this one i did about you know
90 95 percent consequence
uh which one you're most proud of which
one are you let's let's flex a little
bit here like you do in the film but i
mean like
which one you got i would say i'm most
proud of
the underwater sequences you know i
think
uh spoiler alert no spoiler i mean
uh yeah but without getting going too
crazy into it you know there
you know uh he's a navy seal you know
and he's very comfortable in water you
know
and we really put him in some high
intensity high stakes situations where
he's
he has to uh be underwater
you know doing things for
a really really long time and uh just so
just shooting through those sequences
myself uh
and and also you know jumping in and out
of burning
burning cars you know a lot of a lot a
lot of fight a lot of fighting a lot of
hand-to-hand combat a lot of weapons
training
so we had an incredible stunt team that
that worked with us
on each stunt and and trained me to a t
to be able to be comfortable in these
situations so
it was a lot of fun michael b jordan
here on the rich eisen show again
it is coming out on friday the it being
tom clancy's without remorse
right here on the rich eisenshield has
have you michael b
jordan met michael j jordan yet has that
happened
has there been a michael jordan summit
ever yet
for you no i think at the time
i think at the time i met him it was at
a all-star
an event okay and i literally just like
it was in passing you know somebody was
like hey you know
you know like he needs an introduction
hey what's up this is mike
and i shook his hand and it was like
literally less than 10 seconds and then
it was in passing so it wasn't i don't
even think he knew who i was at the time
i mean at the time or whatever
so uh i guess to answer that question
nope well
how has that not happened yet i don't
underst i i don't
i don't see how that is not yet
i don't know man we got to figure that
out i think the powers that be somehow
we had a
we got to collab on something i don't
know it's the market is too rich at this
point you know
no pun intended
hey however i can get involved in that i
would be all
for such a thing but you know i know
like you take in an nba game uh every
now and then michael you know i mean so
maybe just like you know a hornet's game
lamello is coming into town
you know pandemic's over like maybe we
could get
something going here because i imagine
that's something you'd be into
right i i would definitely be into that
you know maybe you know horn is playing
at lakers at some point you know maybe
you know get a chance you know jordan
comes in town or
maybe i go to north carolina who knows
i'm i'm i'm i'm down for that i like to
wear your head's at
like so are the warriors your team
though or i'm trying to remember
when we had a conversation back in the
day no you're thinking about ryan
like ryan like my director ryan coogler
is from he's from the bay he's a duck
uh warriors fan i mean i grew up on the
east coast so you know
i grew up in knicks fan uh it's been
it's been it's been tough
it's been it's been real tough but as
you know as we get to know these guys
you know like you know lebron kyrie
you know i mean certain players and
stuff you you know you become fans of
and you want to see them win so
you know right now i'm you know i'm
definitely rooting for you know rooting
for kyrie right now and
and uh and brian also man it's it's
tough man it's really tough man you just
you just i'm just happy basketball's
back
you know and and uh i mean one thing we
just got we gotta
figure out these referees man we gotta
we gotta we gotta
just now look i give you the floor i
know you're in the
middle of a junket i imagine there
aren't many opportunities that you're
going to have today
in promoting without remorse if you care
to without remorse have the floor on nba
refereeing you're not going to get fined
michael you know
no i'm actually not i just feel like i
feel like they should really
you know be able to do post-game
interviews
and press it's something so subtle and
so simple you know i mean
obviously you know accountability is a
thing but just
you know us us as you know as fans you
know you know
uh you know journalists to be able to
ask questions to them because they play
a hand in the game just as much as the
players and the coaches
so if the players and coaches are
subject to subjected to you know
questions right no why can't they
and and i think that subtle subtle
adjustment
would uh would normalize a lot you know
i think
it would it would settle some things you
know across the board i i
personally feel that no but what what if
an official though a referee you know
handled that post-game press conference
like kyrie like got there and just went
like this you know in front of the
screen for a post-game press conference
and then just
whatever what what would happen what
questions would would come their way
what type of accountability what kind of
example is that being set so it's like
it's just you know and then i heard
something you know some you know body
says something to me about well are they
getting paid you know millions and
millions of dollars like you know like
the players are as well but
you know it's it's a it's not about
salary it's about the part you play in
the system
you know and if you know we're all you
know organized to play this game you
know of basketball
it can't just be the players and coaches
that are that are scrutinized by the
choices that they make because we're all
human
you know and the game has evolved and
you know uh
you know it's not the same nba that it
was in the past you know the intensity
the play like what's
you know what the tech what's not what's
taunting what's not you know so
to be able to like you know have
everybody's opinion front and center for
everybody to see i think would be uh
i think that would be interesting i
would like it so when you're
wrapping up in your your tv work friday
night lights film work creed i mean
you've been in some iconic
sports um pop culture if you could
name your favorite sports movie what
would that be
michael b jordan favorite sports
movie
i must say wow uh sandlot just popped
into my head that's tough that's a good
one
i'm going i'm gonna be split between any
given
sunday and he got game
i decided he got gaming giving sunday i
think i'm gonna split between those two
and then biasly creed
you can include yourself in there you
could definitely you could definitely
include yourself
i i i mean he got game was
really eye-opening and not just because
ray allen crushed it
but there was a lot of real stuff in
there that not a lot of
films have ever covered exactly that's a
good one right there
yeah no i think that that was that was
that was a definitely one for me you
know any given sunday was just like
super entertaining and
you know friday night lights the movie
was really good you know you got
ah man it's remember the titans you
gotta remember the titans too
exactly man so some tremendous
performances and i guess it's like
capturing the world of of those teams
and those sports
those in sports in a different way that
we're used to seeing them is what really
like stands out in those projects
well michael uh congratulations on this
project um
like i said i know i've got a limited
amount of time with you i'd love to have
you back in my studio and do this again
you've got so many
amazing projects that you have done that
you are doing that so many people love
including this one
without remorse um my kids are jealous
i'm getting to talk to you
because we watch black panther literally
every month during the pandemic
so congrats on everything that's gone on
in your life man thank you rich so much
man tell your family and everybody i
said hello and i look forward to uh you
know sitting down and talking with you
on
on the next one you know so as a
director i got you
okay very good i will take that michael
b jordan right here on the rich eisen
show everyone check out without remorse
tom clancy's without remorse starring
this man
michael b jordan coming up this friday
on amazon prime
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here